on va évidemment longuement parler de la
loi immigration Olivier fort le
Parlement l'a donc adopté hier un vote
du Sénat un vote de l'Assemblée
nationale si vous aviez un mot pour
qualifier la journée d'hier quel
serait-il basculement basculement parce
que ce qui s'est passé est très grave en
fait c'est le renoncement par le
Président de la République à tous les
principes qui ont fondé notre pays
depuis la Révolution
française c'est aussi la fin de quelque
chose que nous avons connu jusqu'ici le
barrage républicain et qui a permis à
Emmanuel Macron d'être élu à deux
reprises président de la République
parce que je vois mal comment
aujourd'hui on pourrait demander à un
écteur de gauche de joindre ses voix à
la droite macroniste pour un scrutin
alors même que en réalité il ne sont pas
un barrage ils ont baissé le pont levis
et ils ont fait rentrer dans la loi tous
les principes pour lesquels en fait
Jean-Marie Le Pen se battait depuis 40
ans voilà ce qui s'est passé hier et
c'est à à regret que je le dis et
j'espère maintenant compte tenu de ce
qu'est la crise interne à la majorité
relative que le Président de la
République aura cette présence d'esprit
ce soir d'annoncer que il ne promulgue
pas la loi Jacques Chirac en son temps
sur le CPE qui avait fracturé le pays
avait fait le choix alors même que la
loi avait été voté et bien avait fait le
choix de ne pas promulguer et bien je
souhaite vous lui demandez vous appelez
ce matin le président de la République à
ne pas promulguer cette loi j'appelle le
président de la République à ne pas
promulguer la loi et à tenir compte des
mouvements d'opinion qui sont nombreux y
compris dans son propre camp de gens qui
lui disent que ce n'est pas possible
d'aller aussi loin et de ne rien régler
sur le fond et d'accéder à toutes les
demandes et de donner une victoire
idéologique au RN hier soir si le RN
n'avait pas voter avec les droites et
bien le texte ne passait pas ils ont ils
ont constitué de fait une majorité
parlementaire sur la question migratoire
qui est une majorité RN LR Renaissance
et bien c'est ind digne
[Musique]